yeah man I mean I think like being
vulnerable is probably one of the
greatest qualities like the greats can
have yeah
um yeah you know I think you know if you
even if you think of someone like hope
we don't look at it's like the most
vulnerable guy he's had some pretty
vulnerable moments on yeah that we don't
really you know think about but right
um is it hard was it because you got
really personal on this album was there
ever like a point in time where you're
like man I maybe recorded some [ __ ] and
you question whether or not you like
like it come out or
you know because when you share your
life like that yeah there's consequences
yeah whether it's your family or your
inner circle or you know just sit that
you don't necessarily want because I'm
sure when you record yeah it's therapy
yeah and then what comes out is
something totally different right right
yeah right I mean there's there there
are those moments but you know
you gotta you know this ain't for the
faint of heart you know you Gotta Have
Courage you gotta be brave
you got you know you gotta understand
that
you know well I I understand that you
know my my testimony can can
can help
you know it's we we all just we all just
really want to know that we're not alone
anybody's going through it everybody's
going through something
and you know I just you know when I'm
when I have those
moments where I feel like
it's been much man my mom might not need
to hear this
I you know I just remember that you know
is this for you might help a fan I might
help somebody else out yeah you know
what I'm saying and you know it's got to
be like an interesting burden to carry
like because you kind of have throughout
your career talked to fans personally
you've probably been like yo yo save my
life well yeah literally and so when you
literally when you're getting ready to
release music you kind of know like damn
this this can affect someone's power
yeah right like I think artists take
that lightly sometimes yeah for the good
or for the bad right and I don't like I
said like I always say you know like
when people when I meet people when they
say you know man you don't even
understand man you you like you you
saved my life and I
um
I'm very serious adamant about saying no
you saved mine hmm
you know by giving me a voice by by
listening like so
we go hand in hand you know what I'm
saying yeah one hand washes the other
it's a very so you know it's the
reciprocity is very important to me you
know and I'm grateful I appreciate it
all